member
[Music]
bolivia is massive and full of
pissed-off narcos with a penchant for
state building and/or murder it's up to
you to murder them first and we're here
to tell you about the things we wish we
knew before we set ourselves to the task
if you like our tips for hunting
high-value targets give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to our channel add your
tips and tricks to the conversation
below let's get to it
step 1 unlock the parachute and grenade
launcher these are essential tools in
the early game the parachute lets you
bail out of helicopters which
occasionally get shot down or ditched by
your fellow players in midair
the grenade launcher is the most
effective defense against enemy
helicopters that chase you once enemy
bases go on high alert so get good with
both
I've got a step to figure out which
style of wildlands you want to play the
stock difficulty and HUD will give you a
fairly casual night if you want the full
ghost experience crank that difficulty
to extreme and turn off your mini-map
and crosshairs
seriously the mini-map is a little
spoiler screen in the lower right corner
turning it off forces you to be in the
world listen to audio cues and actually
search out loot doing this alone can
greatly increase your enjoyment of the
game you can't turn off the entire HUD
however you'll have to leave on markers
and ammo and items because the game
lacks a compass for navigation and
animations to tell you what's going on
with your gun or what throwable you have
equipped step 3 now that you're playing
like an actual ghost understand how to
pick apart an enemy base in some tougher
provinces bases have drone jammers that
look like this
AAA launchers that look like this power
generators sirens and lights the best
way to take down a base is to creep in
and manually turn off the drone jammer
then use your drone to locate and turn
off the power station doing this will
disable the alarms and anti-aircraft
launchers place c4 on each of these but
hold off on detonating them while you
move to the designated mission objective
if you have to go loud blow the c4 and
ensure the base can't radio in
reinforcements or shoot you down if you
have to make a hasty helicopter escape
step four move and shoot tactically in
order to stay silent you have a large
range of tools at your disposal to be
quiet and lethal when you find a group
of baddies start with knocking off
snipers and roaming sentries
unlike many tactical games the range you
get from markers your binoculars or
drone actually line up with the mill
dots or lines in your scope if you can't
risk missing a shot and setting a base
off you can command your squad from the
drone view which is why it's good to
invest early points in your range and
battery life from a drone you can tell
your squad to move sync shot and can
call in rebel mortars all from the
safety of being somewhere else tangos
just got a wake-up call step 5
understand sync shot sync shot can kill
from one to three enemies of any type
depending on how leveled the skill is
designate sync shots from your drone
binoculars or when looking through a
scope you can then kick off the volley
by firing yourself or just by pressing
the corresponding execute key keep in
mind sync shot will go through obstacles
such as mountains and buildings then
their sync shooting with your friends
which is even more fun after designating
targets the rotating circle above each
bad guy will stop moving to let you know
that your friends are actually aiming at
their designated guy and not just
screwing around staring at Lamas history
and step 6 understand how stealth works
in wild lands in this game each gun has
a noise reduction stat suppress pistols
seem to be the best shooting off the
wrong gun even suppress can alert nearby
enemies going prone in general greatly
reduces your ability to be spotted from
enemies both on the ground and circling
helicopters overhead clothing does not
matter and is only for cosmetic effect
depending on your playstyle
learn to lure guards you can shoot cars
to set up their alarms pop lights or use
your drone noisemaker to pull enemies to
a location where their body will stay
hidden
breathe the bush pilots flying phylidia
Flores Elba Kingdom there's so much left
to test in wild lands and we'd like to
see you tribe is running with all your
weapons stowed faster can you launch
vehicles with c4 will your giant
American flag tattoo ever hurt your
secret identity we want to answer these
questions and more but in the meantime
check out our review and progress to
decide one of the many awesome games of
March you want to buy thanks for
watching